one of the reasons i developed my own
anti-bias
program is because a lot of the
anti-bias programs
that i was seeing were actually
anti-white programs and that's not the
same thing
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a social
psychologist dr dina mcmillan welcome to
trigonometry
oh thank you thank you for having me on
oh it's a great pleasure to have you on
uh listen for anyone who's not familiar
with you a lot of people will be but
some won't be
who are you how are you where you are
what has been the journey that leads you
through life sitting here
talking to us well um i studied social
psychology
at stanford university and followed by
working in the field and examining the
world through that lens
which is going to be very relevant to
the conversation we're going to have
today
uh yes it is uh you are originally from
the united states you live in australia
now
you've worked in a few different
disciplines you've worked with abuse
victims tell us a little bit about that
maybe before we get into some of the
other stuff
well i i worked i still do work in
domestic violence i have one of the only
prevention programs available in the
world
it's called unmasking the abuser and i
actually teach the tactics used by
abusers during the earliest grooming
phases of the relationship
and because of covid and the strict
restrictions here in melbourne during
that time
i decided to have a podcast
where i took all of my information and
put it on a podcast
so it's called also called unmasking the
abuser and it's on
all of the platforms wow i mean that
sounds
incredibly helpful and incredibly
valuable because a lot of the time
you know people aren't aware the fact
that they're being groomed
so what are these early signs dina that
somebody can be aware of
when they're getting into this type of
relationship
well the one thing i usually say if i
have a little sound
bite is that look out for too much too
soon
one of the biggest and most reliable
indicators of a potentially abusive
relationship is speed
that they start from the very beginning
talking about the future
too many compliments too many gifts too
much
discussion about how we're going to live
our lives what kind of kids we're going
to have
and it's too soon in the relationship
you barely know each other
and by too soon in the relationship what
are we talking about
weeks months days things sometimes
some of these things show up at the very
earliest stages like someone joking
um on the first date you know oh we'd
have beautiful children
or so or introducing you after the
second date is
as their girlfriend or jokingly oh this
is my future
wife that kind of thing
talking about oh we should take holidays
together we should
um buy a house oh if you were with me we
could have
such wonderful lives together that you
have to be very careful it sounds like a
dream come true but it's really a
nightmare
so there's those initials so that's the
first red flag and what are other red
flags
on this particular journey well at the
same time they're
trying to pull you in and talk about
your life together you notice that
something's wrong
there's a lot of control that goes on
there there will be snipes criticism
contempt for your beliefs so it's like
too much of one and then too much of the
other
and it starts right away it starts from
the very earliest days
it's really interesting and i recommend
the people who are interested in that
check out
your work on that side of things tell us
a little bit about
some of the other areas you've been
working on as well because i think
they're
probably the main thing we wanted to
talk with you about today
well i also looking at what happened
during this covet period with the
violent protests
and the divisiveness
in the rhetoric that we're hearing i
decided to put together a program called
healing the rift
because as a social psychologist we
learn a lot about the brain how we learn
how we're influenced
but we also learn flow on effects and i
was
looking at the the narrative
and the focus and the tactics being used
in anti-racism programs and it was very
evident to me from the beginning that
they would have the
exact opposite impact that they're
likely to increase
racial divisions so i decided to put
together
a program called healing the rift to
talk about bias
because a lot of what is being called
racism
is actually racial bias based on
exposure
based on information and i'm not saying
bias doesn't count
it does but it's much more easily
remedied than making a conscious choice
to disrespect or hate people who are
other races dina there's a couple of
things i want to unpack there
so let's start with the first one i'll
come back to the second one the first
one being
and you know to me it was also
self-evident that this would be the
consequences
but how did you know as a social
psychologist that this so-called
anti-racism training would actually
increase uh racial
tension well i knew and it's interesting
because i i told my
listeners for my podcast series um
and i'm going to tell your audience now
the same tactics
i was seeing abusers used to lure in new
partners
and take over their lives and lead them
astray
i was seeing social movements do the
same thing
so once you recognize the tactics
of not just influence but manipulation
gaslighting once you know those
you can apply them anywhere in your life
not just to romantic relationships
and i was seeing the social movements
use these same manipulative
even abusive tactics to
get their message across like what like
what dina can you give us some examples
of
some of the things that were being done
that set off the alarm bells for you
well one of the simplest examples is
having protesters go past
restaurants where people are sitting
outside and eating
and forcing them to do the black power
salute
in order not to be harassed by the
protesters
and as a student of history and
as a former military brat who went to
high school in germany
i recognize that sort of methodology is
something
the nazis used to do they used to force
people to give the nazi salute
so i looked at that and i thought you
know having a slogan
is not the same as having a policy
you know black lives matter yeah well
they do
and i also wanted to quickly explain to
your british audience why
that's such a big deal um in the states
there there is sometimes among
very biased law enforcement uh
the use of a term nhi whenever blacks
are involved in
a crime and that means no humans
involved
and if you study the judicial system
you'll see a lot of disparity between
what happens to a white person who
commits a crime and
what happens to a black person who
commits a crime
so that is where the impetus came for a
you know a
movement like black lives matter but
they took
a slogan and an issue and everything
they did made it worse
so you're saying everything they did
made it worse can you give us some
examples please
um violent protests having 245
violent protests often taking place
in black communities so encouraging
people who are frustrated with their
lives first of all
to look outward for the problem let's
blame it all on the police
let's burn down city hall let's burn
down
the stores let's loot the stores in our
neighborhoods
how in the world is that going to make
people less racist
billions of dollars of damage how in the
world is that going to make people less
racist
it's a good point dina their counter
argument would be look you know we've
tried peaceful process before
this hasn't happened we need to do
extreme measures in order for our aims
to be
you know fulfilled yes
but it's the same you cannot threaten
people
to accept you and i have also as
as someone who works with relationships
not just abusive ones but healthy ones
too
i've never seen anything work if the
effort is only on one side
so now we have a movement that's
teaching whites that all of you are
racist
all of you are wrong being white equals
being
a white supremacist with no effort
expected on the black community to look
at
what are we doing that is leading us
to these poor results is there anything
we can do to improve
there's not a lot of emphasis on that
and that is always a problem
and i want to talk about your solutions
and your approaches in a second but
you mentioned the difference between
racism
and racial bias can you
break that down for our us and our
audience because
that is a distinction that is rarely
made well
it's rarely made and it's funny because
i'm putting together some short youtube
videos
and my first one is going to be called
why you're not a racist
and the simple reason is because they
switched the definition
racism used to be a conscious choice
where you said my race is superior all
other races are inferior
i disrespect i dislike i even mean harm
to those other groups
now they've switched to two if you have
a certain tone of skin you
absolutely must be racist now that
doesn't mean there isn't racial bias we
have
a lot of messages social messages built
into our environment
that show blacks one way
whites another way and that can lead to
bias
bias is just a a predisposition
positive or negative against a person or
a group
so it you can be i'll give you an
example
over this covet period for some reason
i've been meeting all these wonderful
women
named carol or carolyn so i
recently had an interview with a woman
who's writing a chapter in a book i've
been asked to write a chapter in
and her name is carol so i apologize to
her
because i was positively predisposed
towards her
even before she said a word because i've
met all these wonderful carols and
carolyn
it can be positive too but bias
is just having a little bit of
your mind made up before you actually
even interact with that person
that's not the same as disrespect
dislike
and even an intention to harm
but isn't the problem as well the fact
that you know we're just more biased
towards people who look like us sound
like us
come from similar communities so then
when you have someone who comes from a
different community
who looks different it's going to be
more of a challenge for them to get the
job
then somebody you know who who is
different to them
so wouldn't that feel like racism as
well the fact that they're always having
to
prove themselves and do a little bit
more to secure a position and so on and
so forth
absolutely all of us have bias every
person has a bias
and it's based the foundation of bias
is a perception of us and them
so the solution is pretty simple we in
my program we go through
a few exercises you can do to widen the
scope
of what you consider us
so as long as you see someone as them
you're not going to utilize as much
cognitive energy to process
that person you'll make up your mind
more quickly
you'll be way more heavily any mistakes
that they make
but you can stop yourself in the middle
take a deep breath and reprocess
that it's not even that hard
and what level do you go to because to
me that sounds like a good argument for
uh like a nation state let's say like
the like
we can all come to america and we can
all say well i am an american
or we can all come to britain and we can
say well we're all british
and that way the divisions within the
country potentially become less
important
because we're all british doesn't matter
what our skin color is our religion
we're all british but then the problem
is if we say well we're all british then
we're sort of legally obliged to hate
the french
and then right and then we start a war
and then before you know it
you're in world war three so how far do
you take
this expansion of what you perceive as
your tribe
well what happens though is once you
start to expand who you see as your
tribe
you're not as inclined to just go to war
with people
all it will take is a few nice french
people to come over
with some wine you know some nice nice
little nibblies
and all of a sudden they're not them
anymore they're they start to kind of be
us
and you start talking about you know we
decent people
against the bad people and it changes
now i grew up military i mentioned that
one of the things that's really
interesting growing up military is when
you live on a base
all of your neighbors don't look like
you
oh you have a lot of intermarriage where
military people go overseas and marry
someone from that country
you're assigned housing so you're not
allowed to use your own bias to
determine what neighborhood you live in
and it's interesting how many of those
divisions start to mitigate
once you live next door to people so
that's not
you know the vietnamese people are a
real problem it's you know
joe was really there for me when my mom
had a heart attack and
you know this person helped me put my
cable up and
it starts to really change your idea
about us and them so i did have an
advantage
going into social psychology based on
the fact
that i'm an army brat and i think i
already know the answer to this question
so what do you think of
initiatives like anti-bias training
somebody coming in and leading a
training program do you agree with that
or do you think it needs to be done more
organically
well one of the reasons i developed my
own anti-bias
program is because a lot of the
anti-bias programs
that i was seeing were actually
anti-white programs and that's not the
same thing
um i wanted no no blame and shame
talking about the fact that we all have
biases
looking at examples that have nothing to
do with skin tone you know my sister
ia who lives in minneapolis she did some
of the training with me
over your summer and she uses an example
of having a bias against a guy
who was applying for a job because his
shoes weren't shined
and coming from a military family we
were taught that was a sign of
disrespect
now talking about somebody's shoes has
absolutely nothing to do with racism
i think a lot of the anti-bias programs
that we have
put the onus completely on
whites to change their thinking without
any acknowledgement that first of all
some of the bias is always going to be
there because
we're more comfortable with people who
think like we do
and believe like we do and also they
don't really
when you're starting on the back foot
you're not necessarily going to be very
open to the teachings i just think that
they they start off
with you know all white people are bad i
would hate that
i felt like as a black person i had to
come forward
because i can't stand bullying i don't
care who it's against
and i saw white i never thought this
would happen
i saw white people being bullied and i
just couldn't stand it
hey constantine how are you feeling good
and your mental health i'm from russia
we don't have mental health
well in the civilized world we talk
about our mental health
and how we're feeling about our place in
the universe
in the words of my uncle vlad that is
why we will crush you
well he's two months away from a
breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm
that helps you to negotiate the tricky
modern world
it's okay to need help sometimes and
calm can provide support
calm has been really useful for me you
can clear your head with guided daily
meditations
improve your focus with calm's curated
music tracks
and drift off to dreamland with calm's
imaginative sleep stories
narrated by soothing voices like killian
murphy
and stephen fry oh killian save me
man up drink vodka feel better if you go
to calm.com
trigger you'll get a limited time offer
of 40 percent off
a calm premium subscription which
includes hundreds of hours of
programming
and new content is added every week over
1 million people
around the world use calm to take care
of their minds
yes trigonometry fans get special
limited time promotion 40
off premium subscription take advantage
of this amazing offer go to com.com
forward slash trigger
for 40 off unlimited access to calm
entire library
that's com.com forward slash trigger
do you think part of the problem is dina
is that
because we we've all moved forward as a
society we're more tolerant look there's
still a way to go racism still obviously
exists and no one would deny that but
isn't part of the problem
for a lot of black people especially
older black people
you know living in the 80s the 70s or
60s they've experienced
real racism real bigotry that
in a way isn't this just unprocessed
trauma as well
absolutely absolutely and it's it's
really interesting i use an example and
i've been talking to some of my
colleagues in the states about this
and it's led to some interesting
conversations uh when i first moved to
australia
in 2004 um i had family
come and visit me but i didn't go back
to the states for two years
now my family my dad retired to tucson
arizona
and i thought oh it's just it's okay
kind of unfriendly but it's okay
i went back after two years in australia
where
people didn't assume i was dangerous
people didn't assume
that they knew everything about me but
when they saw my skin tone
and i didn't realize how much it had
changed me beyond my conscious awareness
and constantine that's what i mean about
the different areas of the brain that
process
information i went to tucson and it was
a totally different place for me
everywhere i went everyone was talking
to me
whether i went to a restaurant or a cafe
or you know the
checkout line um at the chemists
everyone was suddenly so friendly and
the political situation hadn't changed
the only thing that had changed was me
and you can hear you could not look at
me and say oh i'm sure she lives in
australia
i sound like i just arrived yesterday
i still sound very american they had no
way of knowing
but my nonverbal behavior my lack of
defensiveness
made a huge difference in how people
interacted with me
so while we're trying to get rid of bias
and racism and whatever else negative
that we want to get rid of
let's teach both sides let's teach
people who've been discriminated against
how to relax when they're interacting
with people have an expectation of
acceptance
and see what happens well dina one of
the things you you mentioned
and actually was something we were
talking about before we started so let's
get into it now because i think it's a
crucial piece of this
we are having what i mean could be
described as an intellectual discussion
here
right not when i take part correct but
when i'm involved we're having an
intellectual discussion
but what you are really talking about
and this is something i found
very powerful and very interesting about
your approach which is why we were so
keen to get you onto the show
is that you talk essentially about the
fact that
you cannot convince people of what
you're saying
logically we like to joke on the show
about destroying people with facts and
logic
and essentially your your your senses or
your experiences and your beliefs as a
professional
that doesn't change minds because this
stuff is taught at the level of emotion
talk to talk to us about that
yes well one of the things that i teach
even in the in the seminars that i do
for thirteen fourteen-year-olds is i
just i use
paul mclean's triune brain theory
now there's a little bit of controversy
about it is being too simplistic but i
find it to be a wonderful device
because it basically divides the brain
into three parts
and talks about the fact that they
process information
differently and all at the same time
now if you look at and what is really
fascinating is that most of us
are so attached to our knee or neocortex
our intellectual brain the language part
of our brain
but it's only responsible for between
five to
eight percent of our life decisions
the other 88 to 95 percent are made
using primarily primarily the limbic
brain which is the emotion center
and our reptilian brain which is the
primal reactive part of our minds
so when people have a belief that
motivates them that they cling to
that means that that belief has gone
into their limbic mind
and it may even have been fear-based or
desire based and therefore in the
reptilian brain
so if we're going to change their
thinking and their attachment if we're
going to dislodge
this error in thinking we have to use
the same
sort of mechanisms that implanted and
embedded that information
in those parts of the brain so in other
words if feelings don't care about your
facts
how do you convince people to
listen to what you're saying which is
yes bias exist
yes prejudice exists but saying all why
people are evil
isn't the way to solve bias and it's
actually going to make it worse because
let's be honest
it's been going on for quite a while a
lot of us have been saying
this is bad this doesn't work this
reminds us of certain bad things
and it's only accelerating so how do you
do it
we have to get together and do more than
just discuss it we have to use
the influence mechanisms that are the
most effective we have to use
storytelling we have to get role models
we have to use role play we have to use
music music lyrics
we have to use all of these mechanisms
um
the what i call the three a's which is
attention
admiration and acclaim so we have to use
who gets a re
uh an award or a reward who gets the
attention about something
we have to use the same influence
mechanisms that the other side used
to make people believe these things
to dislodge these things to give us some
something a bit more concrete on on that
front what are you talking about exactly
well you look at who gets the attention
okay
um carolyn m west is a professor
at the university of washington and she
is helping me
with a revision of my original book
called buddy says he loves me where i
outline the tactics used by abusers
and we are specifically targeting black
women in america
and she has worked her whole career on
this and we've
we've been talking about the imagery
projected by things like cardi b
and cardi b's popularity and the fact
that cardi b
was the one black woman selected to
speak to then candidate joe biden
when you do things like that it's like
saying
okay who gets to actually have a public
audience with the queen where it gets
lots of publicity that has a huge
impact on on what that those primal
parts the the emotional parts and primal
parts of our brain
perceive as important even if we
intellectually dismiss it those parts of
the brain are more powerful than our
intellect
and they don't have a filter so they
take it all in
and our brain is programmed
pre-programmed
to adapt so we start
first by being less shocked and then by
being more accepting
of these values so i'm looking at all of
this
you're cardi b really that's the black
woman not a black scientist
not a young black girl who's you know
worked hard in her community
to improve things for the average person
living there
the role model is the woman who is a
former stripper who talks about
having robbed her john's and
presents herself in the most
pornographic way possible this is who
they have held up as an icon for young
black girls
would you not argue though dina that is
a sign of racism though
because what it's saying is you know for
example
that that is all that that particular
sectional community
are capable of for example that's the
thing that we should uphold about
about them not you know the business
owners
the intellectuals the academics etc etc
are you saying joe biden's racist
well if you don't vote for him um
i absolutely think it was racist but i i
look
one of the problems about stereotypes
and racism and even strong bias
is that it doesn't just impact how other
people
other tribes think about your tribe it
will influence how you think about
yourself oh absolutely
and i'm looking at how many young black
people accept this give awards to these
people they say
oh my goodness you know the presidential
candidate
actually spoke with her so this is
something we should admire you saw all
the tick tock videos
of people you know dancing and doing
even small
children doing these things and
i watched in horror because i know
not only were they replicating the
values
that were being presented it was going
into a part of their brain
that's going to take real effort to
dislodge that
but it's not going to lead them anywhere
good
dina i guess what what i i'm asking you
in terms of what what can be done i know
that
your program healing the rift will be
part of that of course but i was
thinking in a more selfish way like what
what can we
what can people watching this at home be
doing like for us
i guess we've had a number of prominent
black intellectuals on the show who are
concerned and critical uh about some of
the things that are being done
and through the example of them talking
about it i know
many many people who watch our show who
maybe were sitting on the fence
many black people but seeing the example
of a of an aisha
can be of an anaya fellaire neman or
azubi or
glenn lowry or yourself or other people
we've got
in the pipeline i think opens their mind
somewhat
is that one of the things that we all
ought to be doing is giving
you know a voice and a platform to
people like that absolutely because
attention is
part of it you know one of the ways of
of
processing information how our primal
child
brain that still makes a lot of our
decisions
it is so important who gets the
attention who gets to actually tell
their story
it's a huge influence you'll notice that
any cause that is being promoted
gets a lot of attention people who are
part of that group
get a chance to tell their story always
from a sympathetic perspective
and it has an impact so yes paying
attention
actually listening actually thinking
about it is a big deal
but we need to also those of us who want
to change things whatever race we are
we need to do things like lawrence fox
run for office
we need to write films and stories
that have these values in them that
actually show things
i am actually looking for funding right
now actively seeking funding
i want to do an online youtube course
on influence because i want to show
everybody in the world
how the brain works and how we're being
influenced
to believe things and to advocate for
things
that are actually not in our best
interest and may even be destructive
and i don't want to just preach at
people i want to show you how your brain
works
and you've touched on youtube again
another part of the puzzle is social
media
because the reality is you know the the
most divisive voices are the ones that
get elevated on social media
because they have the most engagement
yeah 60 000 followers though mate come
on
[Laughter]
well yes i but i have to say i don't
consider
myself divisive no no no no no no
we weren't talking about you we weren't
talking no no no no
it is easier well one of the things that
you may not be aware of that a lot of
people who think like i do who look at
a lot of the policies being advocated by
the people that are being
that are often called the woke um
that if you are against
anything they believe you are absolutely
abjectly rejected if you're black you're
called all sorts of names but on the
other side
if we label ourselves conservative there
is an expectation
that we claim that racism is a lie that
currently there's no racism anymore
it's all about personal choices so
for people like me i'm kind of stuck in
the middle because i
am a social scientist first and foremost
and i
have seen too much rigorous evidence i
have too much lived experience
of racism to say it's all gone i
my argument is that the approach that
they're taking to get rid of it is
actually making it worse
so yes social media helps us get out
there but look at the fact
that social media allows us to only
listen to people we agree with
we need to get a claim we need to get a
wider
range of material we need we need the
people in the middle
like me now i know this sounds
self-serving
but i think we need more people in the
middle so that we can get people who
have been
indoctrinated with those what i consider
self-destructive values
they won't listen to the opposite
perspective but they may be willing to
listen a little bit
to someone in the middle and it's very
true what you said about
you know being listening to someone in
the middle
isn't part of the problem dina that
being in the middle is actually very
very difficult
because it means because it means you're
essentially tribeless you're not part of
the tribe on the left
you're not part of the tribe on the
right which means that
it goes against what we're hardwired
because we want to be part of the tribe
and it means you take flak from both
sides he's talking from personal
experience
both of us well i would say this is i
found it interesting because on social
media
and one of the ways that i started
interacting with lawrence fox for
instance
is he made a comment about there not
being racism anymore
and the difference between people who
consider themselves
non-woke and the woke is that i
disagreed with him
and usually when i disagree with woke
people they call me a lot of names many
of them
beginning with c or n and then they
block me
instead he followed me sent me a text
and said okay show me
so when i'm dealing with people that are
more conservative
right now even if i disagree with them
i'm not so summarily rejected
as i am from the people
in the progressive left the woke people
they they do not allow
any dissension of any degree without
complete rejection
and what do you think that is dina
because it's something that i've noticed
particularly
like people are friends that i've got on
the right you know we will talk and
we'll disagree and
you know i'll be fine and then we move
on uh friends well i don't have any
friends left on the left
i've been summarily expelled well most
of them anyway
why is it that those people on that side
of the argument
are so intolerant because their world is
intolerant their tribe is intolerant
because
people like me come along who spent
years and years being educated how
to dissect research
to see whether or not it's credible
most of what they're being told would
not hold up
to scrutiny a lot most of the research
that they're presenting to support their
arguments
i turn to the methodology page and i go
on social media and comment if i had
written something like this
for my doctoral dissertation i never
would have graduated
so when you're dealing with with people
who
cannot afford to have the light shine on
their beliefs
because then you see all the little
critters in the middle of it it's got
maggots in it
they teach people willful blindness
that's that's how they have to to
act if they're going to keep their their
numbers so large
and you talk about willful blindness do
you think that's part of the reason why
the young people tend to be more woke
is it because they're more
impressionable is that they're more
idealistic or is there something else
going on
and i suppose the second part of that
question is stats show that women
tend to be more woke than males on the
whole is there a reason for that as well
well i would say with young people it's
because the executive parts of our brain
are not fully developed
until our mid-20s so we tend to see the
world more in black and white
before we're young we also see
ourselves as invulnerable we see things
in absolutes we get very highly
motivated by things
everything's emotional that starts to
dampen down by the time we get to the
mid-20s and we start to see the shades
of gray
now women one of the issues too as much
as i have issues and problems dealing
with
with black people around a lot of issues
when i breathe bring these things up i
also
often have problems with women because
women are brought up
to be nice and that being nice is more
important
than being respected so
if something seems you know if you have
someone we're taught to be extremely
compassionate even
at our own cost so whenever a cause
is supported by sob stories
women were off often sign on come on
board
full on not asking themselves well wait
a minute what is the other side of the
story
is what they're saying really true how
is that in
going to impact people like me how is it
going to impact my children
they're not asking any of those
questions because that's not how
most women are socialized and normalized
we're taught to be an easy we're
easy for sob stories to take advantage
of we're taught
the people used to call us
bleeding hearts you know the kind of
person that anytime somebody seemed sad
you
you signed with them most women are
socialized that way
in fact it's one of the reasons when i
do my unmasking the abuser
workshops i have a segment that i've had
to include
teaching women how to say no
because most the time if the abuser
is able to cry tell a story about their
hard life
make them feel like you own you're only
picking on me because i'm whatever
the woman will back down and i have to
teach them not to do that because women
are socialized differently
hey kkk do you like feeling silky and
smooth like a
sexual dolphin never talk to me again
what if i told you that
manscape to brought out a new and
improved lawnmower
3.0 that allows you to be fresh
and trim for the ladies down below
i'm married the last time i was fresh
and trimmed down below jimmy savile was
a respected children's entertainer i'm
going to ignore that
the lawnmower has a cutting edge ceramic
blade which reduces the risk of having
an accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot
you know los were boss oh right
plus it's waterproof which means you can
groom in the shower
and it has an led light so you can
really get an
accurate and precise trim excellent
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes
so you can do your whole area in about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code
which is of course tricker20
your boss will thank you excellent
it's so interesting you you reminded me
of one of our very first ever interviews
with a guy who who doesn't have much
profile but uh called jeremy shapiro and
when we asked him our last question
which we'll ask you
uh which is what's the one thing we're
not talking about that we should be he
said
the power of the media and the the not
he wasn't talking about the like the
mainstream media just the media in
general
uh whether that's social media youtube
the mainstream media whatever
to create impressions and ideas in
people
through a story so and what i think the
example he gave was
even if every night for the rest of your
life cnn runs a story about a bear
eating
somebody that does not mean that you are
in danger of being eaten by bears
because the statistics show that bears
almost
bear attacks almost non-existent but if
cnn
or fox news or both of them were still
run that story every night
people are going to be terrified of
bears i remember actually
doing an nlp course a long long time ago
and the guy who was running it saying
how jaws was a great
great movie for him because suddenly
people living in in the
sort of flyover states of america had a
terrible phobia of sharks and he was
making loads of money
curing it and so how much of this
is really about the fact that we live in
in a technological society now where if
you see
one person being badly treated then
by let's say a black person badly
treated by a police officer
we're not capable of contextualizing
that with enough data and enough
research and enough other stories and
and also understanding why police behave
the way that they behave
we just go like i would not want that to
happen to my son
or to my daughter or to my brother and
to my father and therefore
i don't care about all that other stuff
there's the narrative
you know the police are evil you know
this is what we need to do how much of
all of this is simply the fact that as
you talk that primitive part of the
brain
just goes well that's why i am
absolutely determined and i'm hoping by
doing publicity like this i can get
some benefactors i can get some sponsors
and support
once people understand how our brain
works and how
no matter how intellectually intelligent
you are
the parts of our brain that influence
our emotions and
influence those primal responses have no
filter and will adapt they have been
pre-programmed in our
dna to adapt you become much more
protective
of what you allow in your brain
so it's it it's something that everybody
needs to know i can explain it to kids
and they get it and it absolutely works
but
i know it's disappointing but the first
thing they told us when we got to
graduate school
was knowledge of a phenomenon will not
make you immune to its effects
and i need to show people why that's
true why
when shows and programs and social media
sites
are supporting values or telling stories
with values when the music has values
that go against what you believe to be
right and true why you have to turn it
off
why telling yourself oh but it's got a
good beat
or i watch that show because i like that
one
character no you can't do that
you have to protect your brain
is that really true though i mean look
i'm yeah i'll i'll be honest with you
give you an example right
i think all of us actually would i don't
know
i don't want to slander anyone but i'm a
big fan of gangsta rap
right i've never shot up a anyone
i've never sold drugs i've like none of
the things that they talk about
in the rap lyrics i've ever done or been
tempted to do
ever but it has a good beat to it
and it's going into your mind but but i
haven't done anything have i
no you not yet because you're not in the
circumstances
that allow that but again when you're
buying
music when you're supporting the music
what are you supporting
and what about people who are more
sensitive what about people who are in
those circumstances
what about situations where
a decision has to be made in a split
second
it's going there none of us are immune i
know it's
it's boring to say this but i i don't
advocate for anything i don't do myself
i am very careful
about what i allow my brain to normalize
even in programs that i like films that
i like
if they are advocating for values that i
don't believe in i turn it off
really i know how my brain works my
intellect my knowledge
will not protect me because i'm not in
control
of the majority of the my brain that
makes my life decisions i'm just not
that's i mean i i've never heard
this this argument espoused but it's now
in your head and you can't get it out
yeah exactly but so so
where would you stand dina on
it's just a message and what about the
person producing the art
what about if the person is a
problematic person but produces great
art
do you still would you say that that the
arts and the artists are divorced
he's a michael jackson fan yeah
basically
um it it gets
complicated because if you really
there's a part of us that wants to like
the people who produce
content that we admire and
when for instance when michael jackson
had legal cases
the people who admired his music and all
the thousands of fans standing out front
had an
influence on the jury it's a challenge
because of course if you
support if you go to their concerts and
you buy their music
you're supporting that person's
lifestyle
so it does get i didn't say this was
easy
but if we want a better world than we've
got
we have some tough decisions to make and
that includes
really looking at the values of what we
allow
in our brains we have to just become
more protective of our minds
it's really interesting coming back to
more to the context of our earlier
discussion because
if you're saying that and i guess it i i
don't have any reason to believe it's
not true it sort of sounds true to me
well you'd kind of at this point have to
switch off pretty much every hollywood
movie
pretty much all of the mainstream news
social media
social media right like
the i mean the institutional taker i
mean and by the way this is an issue
i've been discussing on the show a lot
because
you know if francis and i want to have
kids this is an issue that will come up
is
well education system has completely
taken over as well
so what the hell do you do you find
other members of your tribe and you get
more active
i think the problem we have is the
people who
and i'm going to include the two of you
as members of my new tribe
the members of our tribe have been
incredibly passive
and we've allowed people with other
intent
to influence everyone around us
and if you think it's not harmless it
will influence your buying habits
your voting habits whether you sit on
the school board or not
i had a pac contact me recently and
asked me if i want to run for office in
the states
if they come forward i'm taking it
because i don't have the right to preach
advocacy and activity and and and
showing people that you have a right to
question you have a right to say no
you have a right to look the flow on
effects of what people
are promoting and not put myself in the
hot seat
and that includes moving to a country
which is a lot tougher than the one i'm
in
i mean the the problem is dina isn't the
challenge that you're asking people to
act against their own self-interests
no i'm not i'm asking them to act for
their self-interest
i'm asking them to think beyond today
i'm asking them to gather all of that
strength
i mean for you brits you've got it i
i watched so much footage of what
happened during the second world war
before america came in and you were
standing alone against nazi germany
i've never seen such collective courage
in a people
in my life
you've got it you have the courage now
you just have to act on it
fight social media allows us to find
other members of this new tribe even if
they're not nearby
and that we can start not by anything
extreme
but just by saying no just by asking
questions
just by telling people no i won't be
silenced if what you're saying is valid
i want to see the evidence
i think that's a very powerful message
and actually you've sort of summarized
the credo of trigonometry
there really it's about asking the
questions
looking at the data creating a community
uh
and you know doing things like speaking
to people like you and others
about these issues uh to present people
with the information and they can then
make up their own mind
about the direction that they want to go
in so uh
dina imagine i'm not constantine kitchen
uh co-host of trigonometry
but i am constantly kissing president of
the universe and i've just clicked my
fingers and you are all powerful
and you can do whatever you want to
solve all the racial tension and all the
racial problems
what what do you do um
talk about common humanity talk about
what we have in common
um enjoy the differences
hold everybody accountable for what they
do
[Music]
fix tell people fix yourself first you
know
before you demand all of these things or
other people let's fix ourselves first
and i just want to make a brief point
from everything i've studied and having
lived in the uk
as well as in eight states in the u.s um
i've lived in germany france now
australia
racism in the uk is not as extreme as it
is in the states
and it's in the states it varies
depending on where you are
but when you're having people talk about
how racist the uk
is it is not as racist as the us because
slavery wasn't such an integral part of
your culture
and but i think once people
find something in common once they can
laugh together once they can eat
together
okay maybe not for the english sorry
but everybody
and then we call it our own that's why
our national dish is now curry
well you know fishing i like fish and
chips
so you've got that at least but once
people can get together
and look at each other and stop let's
take the capital letter off of us
and the capital letter off of them make
it a small letter
and it's amazing how much we can learn
from each other how much we can enjoy
each other why
let's get back to enjoying each other's
company
instead of seeing each other as enemies
do you think we've gone too far down the
road though particularly in the states
we're seeing each other as enemies
no because there are people like me they
should never let me study social
psychology
no that was that was their mistake if i
got
into any position of influence i can
actually produce i can write scripts
i've done it before i can produce
content commercials public service
announcements
that can show people that can start
telling a different story
and start undermining this divisive
message that is setting us at each other
as
enemies well i'll tell you what i know
you're looking for
for financial support and everything but
i i think if you start putting stuff out
uh even just you talking at the camera
and
you know you send it to a few people you
show it to people it will start getting
spread around
and if it's good which i'm sure will be
you will get the audience and then the
support will be there whether
one wealthy person comes in or and
supports you or not so
i hope you do that i hope you you keep i
am doing it i know you are
i know you i hope you keep going is what
i'm saying um well
i would say thank god for youtube so my
my vid my first video on what why you're
not a racist
should be out within the next week or so
followed by
bias isn't bigotry okay so i'm i'm
trying to teach people what's going on
that the message that mainstream media
will not tell you
so that you can't start healing
from a place of being kicked constantly
let's stop kicking each other and start
communicating
so it's a really great message and i
look forward to to seeing the videos
and i'll be doing my best to help you
promote them but
um we've got one more question for you
dina which is what is the one thing
we're not talking about
but we really should be we're not
talking about what we have in common
you know everything is about how you're
intrinsically different from me
you don't understand my world i'm
we're not looking for the commonality
and and
building from there and i think that's
our mistake
i think that's a really good point uh
and a very
refreshing take on all of these things
which i think is much needed
uh dr dean mcmillan thank you so much
for coming on the show and thank you
everybody for watching we'll be back
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one
all of them go out at 7pm uk time take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below